y aún hoy en 2022 eh Juan Carlos eh
tengo que empezar con un tema que no es
ameno pese a toda la pompa y toda la
belleza que rodea Generalmente a la
monarquía todavía estamos teniendo
discusiones alrededor de la monarquía
británica en torno a temas de racismo de
escándalos sexuales y de discriminación
Y eso también hay que decirlo y quiero
pedirle que Comencemos hablando de
racismo y la figura de Megan a markle
con sus denuncias que enlodaron y
marcaron momentos difíciles en el último
tramo de reinado de Isabel II
es un tema muy ágil y sensible para Gran
Bretaña porque recordemos que hay una
población migrante desde los años 50s
que comenzó a llegar masivamente a Gran
Bretaña sobre todo de India Pakistán
bangladesh pero también de África del
norte de África Central de antiguas
colonias británicas Y entonces hay una
población
afro británica muy importante Entonces
el caso de la esposa del príncipe Harry
y los supuestos prejuicios en su
embarazo pues obviamente no solamente
afectaron a la corona pero afectaron un
poco esa relación de la corona con esos
migrantes de segunda tercera cuarta
generación que son británicos y que ya
pues nunca han ido a África y ninguno
tampoco han estado en India entonces
creo que fueron una relación tensa muy
complicada y muy difícil Seguramente se
ventilaron cosas que se dicen en en las
cocinas y eso trascendió en la prensa
Y pues obviamente golpeó muy fuertemente
a la corona británica sin hacer la
tambalear es una corona que sigue siendo
muy fuerte el 15% de los británicos
piensan que debería desaparecer la
monarquía y que Gran Bretaña Debería ser
una República pero en general hay un
consenso que la monarquía y el jefe de
estado sirven y son fundamentales para
la unidad nacional bueno Y además de
temas de racismo que todavía están en
discusión y que deberían francamente
estar en el centro de la posición de la
monarquía como una figura de respeto y
además como una figura de representación
del pueblo pues está el caso del
príncipe Andrew que finalmente sale bien
Librado después de haber sido
relacionado con El Magnate de Jeffrey
epstein y con nuestras redes de trata de
niñas durante décadas y después de
llegar simplemente a un acuerdo con
Virginia Jeffrey que lo denuncia por
abuso sexual por por hacer avances con
ella cuando era una mujer menor de
Qué opinión le merece a usted de este
caso y cómo se diluyó tan rápidamente
dentro de la prensa y digamos dentro de
la misma monarquía
Pues yo creo que pasó el príncipe Andrés
De héroe a Villano recordemos que él
estuvo en la guerra de las malvinas que
es una característica bien interesante
de la monarquía británica Y es que todos
sus miembros pertenecen a alguna de las
fuerzas o de la Armada o la fuerza aérea
o la Infantería es una contribución al
país y el hecho que este héroe de la
guerra de las malvinas terminar
involucrado en algo tan escabroso como
la trata de menores de edad y toda la
red de prostitución que
montó epstein y su esposa pues
obviamente golpeó muy fuertemente a la
monarquía que que reaccionó muy bien Es
decir lo apartó completamente de todo el
ceremonial lo apartó de la familia y
bueno la causa judicial sigue de alguna
manera se podría se podría avivar en
cualquier momento Entonces eso le va a
respirar en la nuca al príncipe Andrés
hasta el día de su muerte muy
seguramente y yo creo que ya está en los
clasicismo no volverá
a ser parte de la familia real ni de
todo su ceremonial al cual estamos
acostumbrados que hace parte fundamental
de la monarquía británica en parte
porque ellos no tienen una constitución
escrita y en parte Porque se basan en la
tradición y la costumbre Entonces el
hecho de escribir al príncipe Andrés
completamente de todo este ceremonial
que es muy vasto y muy importante pues
muestra que él prácticamente
políticamente desapareció
hablando de política quisiera que
pasáramos a un tema que sigue siendo de
mucho interés y que seguramente va a
tener que afrontar el Rey Carlos III la
independencia de Escocia y el conflicto
latente en esa región Cuál será el papel
de la monarquía En ese sentido
ese es un desafío enorme porque
recordemos que en 2014 Escocia ya tuvo
un referéndum por la separación y los
escoceses la gran mayoría no siente que
sean ingleses a veces en Colombia
nosotros
decimos y en América Latina pensamos que
ingleses igual que un británico pero un
escocés Busca su independencia lo mismo
los galeses lo mismo los de Irlanda del
Norte entonces claro el Rey en este caso
tiene este enorme desafío de mantener
Gran Bretaña Unido no puedes comenzar
siendo rey de Gran Bretaña o el Reino
Unido y terminar siendo Rey solamente
Inglaterra ese es uno de sus grandes
desafíos y se anuncia el gobierno
escocesa ha anunciado un nuevo
referéndum en parte porque no está de
acuerdo con la salida de la Unión
Europea y de no está de acuerdo con
éxito entonces podemos asistir a un
nuevo referéndum que podría seguir con
otra actitud de Irlanda del Norte
similar y en país de gales podría seguir
como unos un juego no cayendo las fichas
al punto que entonces el príncipe o el
Rey actual Carlos tercero sería el rey
de Inglaterra no más de una porción de
la isla y ese es uno de los grandes
desafíos del Rey